do you do bulu we are back with more
podcast in action so much [ __ ] action
in the whole wide world anywhere in the
world who's this my drink is that my
drink and we have X wait then whose
drink is this this is mine oh and those
are the extras hashtag podcast problems
podcast ssssss we are drinking yeah we
always are drinking little note in fact
and by little I mean everyone knows that
we're always just sitting here drinking
the libations all right what are we
talking about today we have we kind of
have a little bit of an open open topic
we I had a couple things I wanted to
touch on regarding UFC jenna said she
wanted to talk about kim kardashian
which is always fun that's not what I
said oh I said I want to talk about
Kanye and Kim so don't leave Kanye out I
was uh missing Kanye so Kim was just
half of what she want to talk about
Kanye as she just told me so Kanye and
Kim uh when we start with that why do
you want to talk about Kanye and Kim no
I want to start with the the UFC okay
okay let start with you see that's
better
so for those who don't know UFC is
called the Ultimate Fighting
Championships it is this it encompasses
a sport of MMA it's one of the biggest
organizations in the whole wide world
and they have fights mixed martial arts
fights which you know just to lay it out
as basic as possible it's a mix of
kickboxing wrestling grappling
it's one of the most popular sports one
of the most fast growing sports in the
world right now it's much much safer
than it looks in fact you can argue that
it's safer than boxing regardless
there's a big fight coming up between a
guy named John Jones and Daniel Cormier
and this is for the light heavyweight
belt John Jones has been a dominant
champion for a long time he's considered
one of the best to ever fight in the UFC
and there was a video that came out
recently and it's it's basically they do
these buildups before the fights at the
stage Julian what what happened in the
video well they're at a press conference
and Daniel is in one of them was he I
was a no no
no you ought to start preface that with
the video that came out because I'm
practicing the video I'm sure no not
that video of them fighting oh yes
absolutely
so there was a media day where they had
a [ __ ] stand your stare down that's
what they cause there that they
basically just stand in front of each
other and stare each other down and then
they take pictures and then use that for
the media it's really not so it's very
old-school but there's a lot of like
reporters like media people that sort of
thing so it's a big giant room full of
people in Las Vegas
I believe this woman was at the MGM yeah
yeah yeah so they're doing this normal
stare down action
and Daniel Cormier who is the Challenger
pushes John Jones but doesn't just push
him in the chest he like puts his hand
kind of on John's face and we've got
some really funny hard it was aggressive
I mean sometimes you get pushed it a
staredown and that's kind of okay you
back up you get separated whatever
notion he pushed him to knock him over
yeah I was day was different it was like
a it was a full-blown first attack and
we didn't punch him but his hand like
hit his neck and John wasn't having it
he went after him and the whole thing
was just a brawl like no one really got
hurt but banner behind them fell down
the guy was like Jurassic [ __ ] Park
in the guy the PR guy ham Dave Charlie
the little UFC PR guy got not the hell
over it was pretty funny so that I mean
that kind of preface this video that
came out but then today a video came out
where it's John and DC in Daniel Cormier
in two different rooms but there are
split screen on the on the screen and
they're hearing each other in each
other's earpiece so they're talking at a
camera but they're listening to each
other so it's basically just like a
trash talk kind of like they do on ESPN
except it was for the UFC so they could
curse and stuff and Daniel is talking
about how fake John is and then he was
like you know what man I wish I was in
that room with you so I could spit in
your face and John said if you did that
I would literally kill you like I would
kill you and he emphasized it like he
wasn't just talking about the fight he
was like no I'm not talking about the
fight like if you did that to me I would
kill you Daniel he kept saying I kept
saying that anyways like serious and it
just kind of got me thinking where it is
you know where does the promotion for a
fight end and where does
you know first of all the law of how you
can threaten someone's life like that
and also kind of just like the
boundaries of being an athlete begin
yeah well Julian told me that story
excited not seeing the video and my
first and immediate thought was you know
that's [ __ ] kind of hilarious because
trash trash talking is fun especially in
the UFC because it builds up the fight
it builds your anticipation like you
really want to see two people go at it
you know as much as a lot of fighters
have so much respect for each other our
friends their training partners you know
something you're you kind of want to see
some people really want to beat the [ __ ]
out of each other absolutely so it's
it's good for the UFC it's good for the
fight it's good for the pay-per-views
whatever but my second thought - that's
[ __ ] hilarious is I wonder what the
law is in that situation like you're
trash-talking because I know in the
state of California at least I read that
if you threaten to kill someone that
that is like taken seriously and then
you can get in real trouble for that in
a lot of states you can say wherever the
[ __ ] you want and I don't think that
there's any penalty for just saying it
you actually have to like you know do
something to back that up to make
someone feel like their life is in
danger but I think in the state of
California you're not allowed to
threaten to kill someone but I'm
wondering you did you look it up I did I
did a little bit of research first of
all this happened in Nevada most of the
UFC fights happened in Nevada whether
you know Vegas yeah Vegas um it's a
fight capital but I looked up the Nevada
state law on death threats and I found
that fear of death or substantial bodily
harm if a harassment allegation in Las
Vegas allegedly caused the victim in
quotes to fear substantial bodily harm
then the DA may instead bring category B
charges carrying a sentence of two to
fifteen years maybe a $5,000 fine here's
something I thousand dollar fine for
killing someone no no this is just the
death threats we're just talking about
the deference the murder I didn't look
I'm just interested in the death right
no because just just to go back to the
whole story like trash Hawking is really
funny but if you're sitting there and
saying I'm literally gonna kill you over
and over if I know
no over are you then above the law
because you're sort of doing it in an
arena where you're hypothetically gonna
kill it well yet for work yeah I mean
like you'd think that because of how
clear he was making himself it would be
different than the trash talk but what I
want to know is what do they do in the
UFC's contract that they give the
fighters does is there a clause about
not pressing charges for like death
threats doesn't have to mean you'd have
to think that the UFC is taking these
precautionary measures in case someone
like John Jay their asses are totally
covered right me that's I'm saying got
to have they have two thousand page
contracts that people have to sign in a
sport where you're literally building up
a fight regularly by saying things
similar to death threats like I can't
not have that covered they have to have
it covered but I just think that it's
interesting because like you know your
First Amendment right you're allowed
freedom of speech but like oftentimes
like in music or in television like
you're not just always allowed to say
whatever you want like as much as you
know you are because there's freedom of
speech you can really get into some
tricky trouble with the things that you
say and how you say them and who you say
them to so like what I said to Julian in
the car that I thought was funny was
like so say for example either which
happens extremely rarely but in a fight
like say John Jones actually did kill
Daniel Cormier or at some other point he
actually did kill Daniel yeah would that
be considered premeditated murder since
he told him beforehand like they would
have no defense because he's already
said so many times I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you before I answer that question before
I answer that's a great question before
I answer that it's never there's never
been a death in the UFC Octagon ever
just wanted to say that there was one no
not in the UFC no one okay okay but in
the sport of mixed martial arts
that's all in common that's like saying
in a baseball game someone died but not
in MLB maybe that's how you got it okay
I get it but no I'm just explaining for
them but um well here's that you got to
think of it so say this happens say John
Jones comes off of the video like you
did
they sing I'm actually gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill you I'm not talking about
the fight I'm gonna kill you then he
goes in and kills them first of all I
think you'd have to pay attention to how
he kills him so is it the refs fault for
not stopping the fight early enough is
it just what we're talking about if he
killed him in the all it wasn't that
your question arose if he didn't kill
him a knock somebody actually just
killed Daniel no it was a who's a
two-fold question if he killed him in
the Octagon yes I was ever considered
pre-med it wasn't murder and if he
killed him outside of the Octagon
that's absolutely premeditated murder I
think you're right on the second part
the first part it'd be very be very
[ __ ] crazy coincidence if a fight
where Jones had actually threatened
murder in the way he did today even
though it was still similar to
trash-talk and then he actually like you
know Lee in a sense it's like it was in
a legal competition and he killed
someone so the odds of that happening
like the odds of someone dying in in an
octagon fight is so minuscule already
because there's there's precautions they
take they get physicals there's refs
there's doctors but I mean if that were
to happen in a fight you'd have to
wonder because you know what like they
could be an argument made that he had
some really kind of not normal trash
talk and he had some ill intentions
right and for the record I think we both
agree and many people agree that
although the UFC does do a fair amount
of like hype like they get them to say
things that they wouldn't really say in
conversation for the sake of the hype of
the fight yes do you don't I mean we
agree and many people agree that this is
not like a PR move this is not like some
cooked up [ __ ] [ __ ] like this is they
really yeah these guys they don't like
each other but let me let me pose a
hypothetical scenario so say like John
Jones like just these people are
enormous what's their weight class 205
pounds but they weigh like 230 pounds
they cut down walking around yeah they
cut down to 205 pounds they are as Ronda
Rousey likes to put it you know you want
to be the most dangerous unarmed person
on the planet these people are
absolutely capable of killing someone
anyone whenever they want and a little
note add there is when you're a
professional mixed martial artist you
have to leave
juster your body is lethal weapon as a
weapon okay um so hypothetical situation
so say that they're there in the Octagon
and the machito fight when john jones
choked him out by the neck like just
your neck and your head or an incredibly
dangerous thing so the ref stopped that
when Machida was out already he was
unconscious but what if in John Jones
brain he you know the refs breaking it
up and he just took one little quick
crack of your neck and oh you're dead
where's the line do you go to jail for
murder are you know on trial if that
happens I'm almost positive he goes to
jail with all the with all that what if
it was before what if he decide to just
in the fight do something illegal and
[ __ ] break his neck well first of all
there are a slew of different kind of
small print rules that the UFC has in
place to prevent this type of thing in
terms of like strikes to the sky things
that can really hurt a person just so
you'd rate murder yeah so I mean if John
John if you had someone in a chokehold
and you see instead of trying to you
know cut off the blood supply to the
brain or whatever he actually tries to
twist the head and the neck it's almost
you know impossible in my brain how I'm
thinking of it for the the group of
everyone whether it's the UFC the
Athletic Commission the doctors everyone
to look at it and be like okay that
wasn't intentional because if he
actually did something like that it's
pretty clear that he tried to do it you
know I mean there's been a million
fights the UFC's been around for years
and years and nothing like that has ever
happened so if it happened it wouldn't
be like oh you know he was choking about
as an accident no like right that needs
to be really really blatant I really
have I agree with you and I don't think
that either one of them is actually
going to try and kill each other but I
think it's an interesting idea that if
in an octagon someone really hated the
other person enough in order to do
something illegal and want to actually
murder that person what are the
consequences for that I think it's just
all about how it goes down you know I
think he could I think someone in a
situation with everything went right not
right but everything went accordingly to
how they would have hoped they could get
away with it because there's been you
know like II said can you enlighten
that don't know a whole lot about the
other deaths within sport yeah he's
gonna get to that perfect yeah and some
of the smaller less regulated shows
across the United States there have been
deaths where people uh when you get
someone in a chokehold and whether it's
you know when they tap or whether they
fall asleep during the chokehold the
reps job is to get in there and stop it
as as soon as they can right you know
with the fighters best physical and
bodily interest in mind so there have
been times when someone held a choke
past the point of tapping past the point
of going unconscious to the point where
they're doing brain damage so the person
is unconscious they haven't had blood to
their brain for ten plus seconds and
then they're out and they're still
getting choked so that's when brain
damage that's when death that's when
paralysis can all happen and it has
happened not in the UFC but in smaller
ships people have died people have
gotten rushed to the hospital and died
later in the night those were they all
from chokeholds or were there any that
were not um you know I'm not sure on all
the facts I know that most of these type
of incidents come from holding chokes
too long and so who's held responsible
for that breath it's it's all dependent
on the situation but are there any risks
that are in jail for like not that I
know of
but I do know that we wouldn't you when
you sign a contract to fight you're
literally signing away your well
obviously your life yeah so when these
people died like that obviously the
person I mean it would be the charge for
that like if you're the ref like
involuntary manslaughter maybe assisted
something assisted murder assisted
manslaughter I don't murder well it's
not murder but then then you they then
again you look at the scenario where
murder but you look at the scenario
where like clearly someone is like
there's been times when people are
holding a choke the ref comes in and
they try to hold it they blatantly try
to hold it against the refs will so
there's situations like that where it's
like okay he was completely ignoring the
rules he was ignoring the voice of
reason here and what are the
ramifications for a fighter like that
are they ever allowed to fight again uh
you know it blows my mind that it's not
just a blanket no because in some of
these small commissions people can get
away with leaving that Commission and
fighting a different commission like
insane yeah I don't really I mean it's
it's all such a kind of a young sport
still mmm
20-30 years it's like the sport of
boxing with a [ __ ] Evander Holyfield
and Mike Tyson was available Holyfield
ever allowed to fight again after he or
Mike Tyson when Tyson bit Holyfield yeah
I don't know
I was I was not super into the boxing
you know I haven't done enough research
to know I don't know I'm pretty sure he
fought after that fight like isn't that
insane dude it's pretty crazy because
there's that should literally never
happen yeah ever yeah well I'm trying to
think of other examples like baseball
[ __ ] Pedro Martinez when he shoved
Don Zimmer or whatever into the ground
but like when you blatantly but that's
one thing if there's brawls and sports
alright there's [ __ ] Carlmont
Washington who's the hermit's middle
name whatever my dog I named her after
I've fight in basketball Washington
Lincoln is another story but um there's
certainly been brawls and inappropriate
things in sports but like when you're
really really really [ __ ] doing harm
to another player I'm not so sure that
you should be able to play again yeah I
have a great example about this man is
it Tonya Harding I'm kidding
Machado no nothing I give nothing I get
no response for that I don't know what
we referring to Tonya Harding in the
Olympics she like she hired like
basically a hitman to go to the her
another American Olympic figure skater
to like I think bash her knee and with a
pipe I'm pretty sure that she never
skated professionally again only like an
exhibition go and he's not joke that's
what I feel like something like as
ridiculous as that can have different
rim occasion ramifications in every
single sport I wanted to bring up this
guy Machado
he's the third baseman for the Oakland
Athletics and he's a real piece of [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate this guy and I well he's
he's got a hot head he's got a crazy
temper and he pushes people he takes
tags personally and there was this one
instance where I really just kind of
lost it with him I you know I feel like
it's kind of a disservice to the sport
to have him keep playing I told you
about this he swung
and missed and blatantly let go of his
back trying to hit the third baseman
like there was no accidental anything
you can't watch this replay and be like
oh it was an accident no one will ever
watch that and think it was an accident
and yet he gets what 15 game suspension
and he's back I mean come on that's a
joke I don't know someone and I played
softball we both played baseball there's
a lot of really really dirty things that
you can do to other players clean them
cleaning people is one of the worst
thing that you can do especially since
you can really jack up you are metal
spikes I mean they're [ __ ] legitimate
weapons and I've seen girls just get put
out and in in a blink of an eye because
of an illegal slide I mean I sort of
thing you think about what's an illegal
weapon just by law okay a gun a mixed
martial arts body a knife and how about
a baseball bat so when you hurl one at
the [ __ ] third baseman who's by the
way probably 80 feet away with his
little you know he's creeping up and I
mean it's like first of all any time
someone let's go over that it goes
flying into the stands right slip out of
your hands it's like it's win right it
does happen but he was like it's always
in your backswing it's never directly at
third-base
well I can link you to the video of that
[ __ ] happening I mean it's bananas I'll
also link you to the Jon Jones and DC
thing but I mean I can't believe that
that fifth like MLB gave him 15 games
that is [ __ ] ridiculous but what
about okay so I don't know a lot about
this because I really don't give a [ __ ]
about football other than like I I like
the Patriots I like the bills
I like wings I like I like chicken wings
that's my deal but so the [ __ ] the
dirty hits by like the Saints and that
sort of thing that they put out hits on
players yeah I do I do remember that
why are those players so a lot of
[ __ ] play cuz they make the NFL
mine I can't think of another reason
Manny Machado selling jerseys these
Saints players who did that our big-time
players I mean it would be too much of a
hit to the organization is corrupt I
understand and they're for any of you
out there I can't even [ __ ] find it
anywhere but on DVD and I don't even
have the DVD the show on HBO called
playmakers that I've told you about that
I feel like you would really really like
and anyone that likes sports and or yeah
NFL would really like I'm not even into
it and the show is [ __ ] fantastic
but the apparently the show was amazing
after one season one [ __ ] season and
the NFL said to HBO like in so many
words you can't keep making this because
it's too real
like there's a gay player like I don't
remember when it came out but there's
the there's gay there's [ __ ] like
drugs there's [ __ ] all kinds of like
really really fucked-up things going on
we're just so true to life and it was
incredible crazy but it's crazy like
when you know things that go on behind
closed doors and sports like what people
talk about you know yeah that shit's
like it's very sorry but whatever third
baseman that you're talking about that's
a learned behavior Jimmy oh my god like
he's always played like that right I
know I know but he he's been able to get
away with it and get a result that is
desirable to him jr. to me like no one
does that without any sort of reward
after the fact like he must have been
doing that for years and years and years
and always got away with it be getting
what he wants out of it though a win
being a win yeah he's a real piece of
[ __ ] you watch like two highlights of
this guy you know I hate him I hate him
but anyways back to [ __ ] thus the
sport of MMA and the UFC yes I think
it's an interesting idea because there's
you know there's rules but in theory
there's no rules you know just [ __ ]
we're just gonna go kill each other
yeah where's the line for like like you
know a lot of poke people you're not
allowed to kick them in the nuts not
allowed to do certain things it's not
that there's no [ __ ] rules but like
in in terms of the line of trash-talking
and then if someone were to actually
really really be on the verge of almost
dead or dead what are the consequences I
mean it's it's just a very interesting
thought to think that someone like Jon
Jones would you know separate the trash
talk you know pretty literally like he
did like I'm not talking about the fight
I'm gonna kill you if you spit in my
face or whatever in a situation where he
you know very clearly separates that
from trash talk to the fight and then
something like that would happen god
forbid god forbid right um but you know
like I said before so many things have
to go wrong for someone to die in octave
so many so many things the the ref needs
to be completely not not off his curb
not I mean no no I mean not off his game
not a bad ref not a slow Rev they need
to be in on it they need to be a hundred
percent letting this happen and actively
allowing it to happen that's happened
and that's not only it like you're
talking about cornermen not hopping the
fence and pulling someone off like
there's so many things that would happen
before someone actually [ __ ] died so
you know it's just it's a very scary
thing to think of it and that's all you
know this whole I'm glad we talked about
this because when I watched that video
today Jon Jones I'll link it like I said
literally kill you it's just yeah made
you think you know like it he really you
know in a sense literally separated his
trash talk from what his intentions hmm
if DC had spin his face forever but yeah
it's crazy
um I would just because I'm selfish and
I like entertainment yeah I would love
to see what actually would go down if
Daniel Cormier actually did spit in his
face I want to see him spit well well
okay here's another hypothetical
situation I'm on a roll um if they step
into the Octagon when they fight what's
the date that they're fighting no no no
I think it's I think in September okay
um so they step in the Octagon you know
we got Herb Dean being like touch gloves
I want a clean fight whatever Daniel
Cormier just [ __ ] spits right in his
face while they're in the Octagon so
your question is what happens like what
well like whether the owner John reaches
out touch gloves and he gets a face full
of spit yeah he gets so say Daniel
Cormier spits in his face in the Octagon
in the very beginning okay all right at
some early part yeah yeah when they're
facing each other since John Jones
already warned him that he will kill him
if he then kills him is that murder is
it murder one is a premeditated murder
or think if any more is that spits out
the fence or is it following up on your
word all you have is your word
I guess he's off the hook because he
already said he would do it so everyone
had a chance to stop it like I don't
know
I think I mean if he came okay say when
they're finished daniel cormier spit in
his face can John Jones murder him in
the Octagon on the stairs on the way out
of the Octagon on the first step yes on
the second step no way no way second so
the first step oh yeah
it's like Wild West on that first step
oh my god
craziness do you think Dana would like
it uh if it was on the first step he
would love it if it was on the second
step Dana would be in hot water
lady get a witch Dana's like talking
trash to me on YouTube I don't know what
that's about
oh I'm just kidding it's a fake Dana
there's a fake dana white account
writing comments sorry completely
unrelated but yeah i mean if you think
about it the way that press conference
in the way that video came out today and
by the way the UFC took it down like
five minutes after it was released which
is brilliant in my opinion makes it all
that more dramatic and exciting they're
all doing really good job happiness like
as much as you want to speculate maybe
show those type though because people
want to see it [ __ ] anyway yes and I
agree with you but at the same time a
lot of people don't know who Daniel
Cormier is you know people know who John
Jones is and he's winning every single
fight but you know hardcore fans like
you and me you know people who
understand the sport have been following
it they know who Daniel Cormier is they
know he was the Strikeforce Heavyweight
Champion no he tossed around Burnett and
Bigfoot they know he's capable of
winning a big fight but to the masses
the people who may or may not by
pay-per-views he's still kind of you
know in a sense unknown he's alive and
he's not on Nike he's not on Nike Reebok
yet he's got a little bit too much of a
potbelly to be a yes yes folks person
for ninety two very good points yeah
she's also not John Jones not John John
uh and but it's it's crazy because he
does have the the resume to boot you
know I mean like he could be as big as a
star as John Jones and he just moved
down to light I think he has two fights
at light heavyweight so far so you know
like he used to be yet I'm John you dick
used to be it I don't need to weigh in
yeah that's her dick these pieces of
[ __ ] for you I just blew it shut up too
this is this those good I'm glad we
[ __ ] touch that I don't feel like we
came to any conclusion well I think the
conclusion is going to happen sadly
enough when someone [ __ ] dies when
someone dies when someone dies okay
we're gonna see what I mean
hopefully that another question UFC if
say okay
say Daniel Cormier spittin john jones
face then john jones tried to kill him
where is this are this in the fighter
where is this in the fight okay in the
fight and instead Daniel Cormier
actually wound up killing John Jones
that murder or self-defense
since he provoked John Jones by spitting
in his face but it was a spit so let me
just get this path of add event events
straight he spit in John Jones face yep
John Jones was blinded by the spit then
Daniel I don't know so wait what did
John Jones do in retaliation he tried to
kill him so he tried to kill DC but DC
ended up killing Jones yeah so what did
Jones do to try to kill DC did he hit
him in the head did he like elbow him do
you throw him what did he do I don't
know you miss it's a plight of course
they're gonna try to kill each other
they're punching each other
Julian my can just play along okay like
you know what's that knockout when they
go to touch gloves or whatever and the
guy says no and then you got alright
fight and you just knocks him right out
or whatever it blows him a kiss yeah so
say instead of that today no car may
spit in his face
John Joel it there they haven't even
started the fight yet like in the center
of the Octagon John Jones goes to kill
being a Cormier like they're not
fighting they're about to [ __ ] great
it's about to go down
Daniel Cormier ends up killing John
Jones in that scuffle yes I would say
that self-defense if Jones goes after
even though the stay nikomia provoked
his pick doesn't matter if Jones goes
after him in an unsanctioned manner and
Daniel wins it was self-defense because
that might as well have been on the
street the fight hadn't started yet
hmm we get a million witnesses watching
that unsanctioned
self-defense of and murder he provoked
him and he was also threatened in
mourned so I have a question if you go
up to someone on the street spit in
their face they try to kill you and you
kill them yeah but
didn't have like a three or three-day
long conversation about how I will kill
you if I spit in your face
that is true so the dead John Jones who
had made comments about how he was going
to kill DC yeah and DC ended up killing
John yeah I would say John's left the
hook he silenced the Beast
alright I really hope neither these guys
ever die nor or anyone in the UFC yeah
we were just thinking about it as well
we're just talking about it
but it took off with it in my brain yeah
it left our brain and and flew into the
crazy verse and then and then yep good
word is it auntie Terrell and hate still
heads if you don't know who Alan
tutorial is it's probably the biggest
troll on YouTube like you think how to
basics a troll he's really the biggest
[ __ ] troll on YouTube yeah he makes
howtobasic look totally sane he makes he
makes how to basics tutorials or how to
videos look like how-to videos
yeah like this guy on tutorial is gonna
make you freak the [ __ ] out like you
done we're just so [ __ ] weird it's so
weird like in the way he talks it's like
you just hey to toriel head I story Oh
heads it's so creepy
so creepy oh man beautiful um so Kanye
West and Kim Kardashian cool I've done
something to spark the interest of my
lovely girl no they haven't done
anything oh so okay I mean so they would
tell me I don't want a lifetime of
things a lifetime yeah I just feel like
[ __ ] I get angry right so I was
getting ready in the bathroom was
putting some makeup on and I'm listening
to Kanye I don't even know what song and
I've just always loved Kanye so much and
I understand that he went through sort
of a dark period in there when his mom
died and he was drinking and dating
Amber Rose not that that's a down side
that's a plus side she's hot I know you
have no idea what I'm talking about
Milan way this is why it's so difficult
to play 20 questions with Julian cuz I'm
like are they dating someone famous
yours like ah no idea it's like
red hit like Angela okay I know that one
one you know Mara Mia Hamm okay that's a
close second I'm so sorry um and God
what what the [ __ ] yes so anyways I was
just thinking about how much I love
Kanye and yeah he was I understand he
went through a dark period but I feel
like Kanye is so misunderstood and I've
sort of sat down and watched a lot of
interviews with him I watched the sway
interview did you watch that at all
um no I don't think so I think you might
have don't want a Jimmy Kimmel like
totally blasted on his show oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah actually it kind of had that
exchange on Twitter or whatever yeah but
they had the exchange because Jimmy
Kimmel did that piece where he had
children playing sway and Kanye okay
okay yeah yeah yeah no no I do I do
actually recall here okay so um I've
watched all of his interviews with
people uh that you know the internet
seems to be like outraged with or like
you know Kanye's a [ __ ] douchebag or
an idiot and I just don't agree I just
don't agree at all
because I feel like not only is he's an
incredible musician which I think a lot
of people agree with with the exception
of his last album which everyone seemed
to have a [ __ ] problem with I
personally didn't I thought his last
album was fantastic yeah especially
since every single album that he has put
out has been a different genre of music
that's [ __ ] insane do you know what I
mean yeah like this last we forget that
there's last one that he put out was
very like EDM like that sort of thing
it's in the house trance music scene
like the one before that is just [ __ ]
- I don't even know what like he crosses
genres of music while staying under the
umbrella of hip-hop but even if I've
heard many people argue I love Kanye's
music I don't like him as a person yes I
understand that but what I think the
problem is that most people have is that
it's easier to write someone off as just
sort of insane
than it is to try and understand them do
you know what I mean absolutely so these
interviews that he has with people where
all
these they take these one-liners that he
say to sort of portray him crazy yeah
yeah he's just not the most eloquent
like if he could just take his words and
put them in concise sentences that made
sense to like more people yeah I think
that people would have a much easier
time taking him seriously when he's
speaking because if you actually try and
sit there and not laugh and like be like
this person's crazy cuz that's easy it's
easier if you sit there and try and
understand the gist of what he's talking
about he's so incredibly [ __ ] right
about everything that he's saying it's
disgusting and it breaks my heart when I
see him getting [ __ ] on all the time and
like I
I like his music I think that he's a
brilliant human being yeah I am not
emotionally attached to Kanye West you
don't I mean yeah I wouldn't say that
I'm coming to his defense because I'm
emotionally attached okay yeah Jenni
meme yeah I just when he was talking
about in the sway interview he was
talking about the fashion industry and
sways whole thing he just kept repeating
like hey man if you want to get in the
fashion industry why don't you just do
it yourself like why do you need these
people
like he goes through that period of
wrapping all these expensive designers
that no one understands and no one knows
what he's talking about
and is completely unrelated to the
general public so we're all just like
Kanye you're [ __ ] insane and no one
knows you're talking yeah yeah and he
went on this big long tangent about just
to summarize it in a way that maybe you
were anyone else could understand
because I actually sat there and you
know like I don't know translated it
into a language that I could understand
was that he's trying to break into an
industry that is not break inable jr. I
mean he's trying to break into the
fashion industry and become something
other than a rapper which doesn't really
exist right the only person I don't know
that I can think of maybe dr. Dre he has
headphones but like that Pete wrappers
and things have the clothing lines or I
don't know what endorsement without
really in the industry they're not like
super crossing into other like yeah
industry yes so to speak they're taking
what they're good
that and then using that to sell other
things response yes Kanye's like whole
idea was I don't want to just watch a
clothing line you know I don't want to
just sell clothes I want to be taken
seriously in the fashion industry which
there was a really good quote that kept
getting [ __ ] thrown into the mud from
the Jimmy Kimmel thing when he's talking
his way he was like you know I invented
these [ __ ] or I came out with these
leg leather jogging pants he's loved
their sweat pants
you know everyone [ __ ] laughed at me
and I sat in Paris like he's just
speaking in broken English yeah i sat in
Paris I told him this idea like nobody
[ __ ] cares man they don't [ __ ]
care they don't care about anybody and
then they did that and then they thought
it was [ __ ] great basically he was
saying Kanye West was trying to pitch
his leather jogging pants his ideas his
brand as a high-end fashion designer
that needs to be taken seriously and
they sort of [ __ ] on it but then you
know less than a year later they came
out with the same thing like a Versace
pant a leather jogging pant and I could
understand why it's so infuriating for
someone that's saying I have good ideas
I would like to execute them yeah I need
a little bit of help I would like to do
it in a way that's not just you know
selling clothes I want to be taken
seriously well the way you're telling
this to me right now it sounds
completely straightforward and easy
downer it's outrageously straight far
right I guess my question is you know
you have a long background in listening
to people that's what your degrees in
you've been a great listener you know
you know and you know I think I think
that's a good explanation for why you
can get get what he's trying to say a
lot of time but I want to know what you
think it is about Kanye that makes him
so hard to really not like emotionally
attached to but just kind of relate to
and understand what each what he is
trying to say because I feel like a lot
when you break it down like you just did
it makes perfect sense like for people
like me and for people who aren't really
you know able to understand or really
pay attention that much to the situation
I mean that you just broke it down very
simply and I think some of the you know
examples you've cited in the past to me
and showed me things it all kind of adds
up and
makes sense that he has a real message
and he's very kind of a smart person he
just doesn't you know express himself
the right way what is it about him that
he struggles so hard to get his messages
um a that he doesn't speak eloquently
Trudeau to me
he has such good ideas I think that he's
a genius but when he talks it's just
like it's all over
it's very passionate and that's it's
almost to his detriment you don't I mean
if he can't form a sentence that would
make someone else understand in a
conversation through music through
rapping we get what you're saying you
don't I mean the message comes across
strongly but if you're sitting and
having conversation he's just very
passionate it's like we talked about
Jacob like topic to topic to topic it's
jumping around there's not a complete
thought where there are really good
thoughts if he would just I don't know
learn how to extrapolate on that in a
conversation I think would help people
because what people see is a brash
egotistical person that's just sort of
spewing opinions and garbage in in words
and phrases and sentences that they
can't understand that makes you dislike
everything that comes out of his mouth
because you don't understand it I
understand it's you yeah yeah like for
example when he interrupted Taylor Swift
at the VMAs or what was it the VMAs yeah
and said you know hold on Taylor I'm
gonna let you finish but Beyonce had one
of the greatest videos of all time and
and everyone shat on him remember he
like hid away for a while for almost a
year I think because he was drunk and
doing that whole thing but I'm sorry was
Kanye wrong or right you know not the
Taylor Swift thing yeah by the video I
was right I mean yeah a single ladies
video I think that was a way more ah do
you even run the breaking video timeout
do you even remember the video that
Taylor was accepting that award I don't
think that most people do unless you're
really super hardcore Taylor Swift fan I
would remember the single ace
I think I think yes I do and I think
also all the people who were saying bad
things about Kanye would answer the same
as I just
correct they remember the single ladies
but they don't remember Connie or they
don't remember tails because they also
just feel like they can because Taylor
Swift you know was just this like
innocent third party like I'm just a
nice girl like why are you interrupting
me but you know so it's maybe that maybe
Kanye didn't need to go about it in that
particular way but he was [ __ ] right
so it's a perfect example of Kanye
having a great point but going about
expressing it in the wrong way maybe
people have a problem with the way that
he expresses it but the only thing that
I really really like I hold on to this
is why I cherish Kanye this way I
cherish the hip-hop community is because
I feel like Hollywood the whole like
music industry actors like they're
handled do you know what I mean they're
told how to act how to live and whenever
someone sort of like goes off on their
own trail and starts getting a little
loose canon ii that makes people panic
you know what I mean because there are
so many people behind an actor or a
movie or a musician that need you to
just keep it together and make everyone
money do you mean whereas in the hip-hop
community you cannot control some of
these people you know what I mean you
cannot tell them what to do because they
a lot of them are just like they come
from nothing think about like the
[ __ ] some of these people in
Hollywood that come from old-school
money they're willing to play the game
they're willing to be told what to do
like if you come from nothing I think
about Kanye's life he started with a
single mom in Chicago just dancing
around and [ __ ] kicking it and you
come from nothing if you start making
money people are not going to tell you
what to do - I mean you don't lose that
sense of self yeah so they interpret him
being a loose cannon like he gets mad at
paparazzi which I totally understand
real real thick you no response to the
rape is realistic I get it you know he
he goes off at the mouth he says things
that he shouldn't say but like without
that what do you have if you took all
the things away from Kanye that make
Kanye what are you left with jay-z yeah
an average nothing like it's not G not
jay-z but that someone who kind of
blends in
the background that's the whole like
spirit that makes him him and if he was
willing to play the game and play by
everyone he wouldn't have the same award
he would just he wouldn't even be in the
music industry he would be no one yeah
that sense of self is what got him to
where he is like why would he ever stop
doing that and he's always [ __ ] right
and it's I feel I feel like it's a
difficult thing because he's all you
know Kanye person like Kanye is always
going to be polarizing and when these
people like with these loud
personalities are famous and they're big
you know successful artists or whatever
they're you know they're like the
referee they're never going to make
everyone happy there are a lot of people
are going to find problems with them and
whether it's the the fact they don't
understand it and they want to just call
it crazy or the fact that they you know
they would rather him just kind of blend
in and play the game like everyone else
you know it's it's very easy to see a
talented artist have good PR because it
happened so much you're used to it and
you expect it but for when I feel like
on the contrary to Kanye jay-z and
Beyonce have incredible PR because well
it's a lot of you know that I'm obsessed
with gossip blogs and you know their
whole marriage falling apart and then
the rumors of them you know being
married for like a business arrangement
and that sort of thing conspiracy
theories but like they are incredible at
keeping their image above everything
else that's their image their business
their everything above everything else
yeah whereas I feel like I identify with
someone that does not want to play that
game and occasionally you get caught
just [ __ ] being you tuning yeah
because I feel put a price on that to me
no it's because it's a real human being
acting like a real human being right the
whole idea I mean when you say playing
the game you're basically saying this
person knows how to fake it first to
notice how to come off like someone that
they are not right and I think that's
one of the biggest don'ts in your eyes
and I would align with that too you
don't want to be someone who is being
represented differently in the media or
differently for other people who don't
know you on daily basis like Kanye I
think that's one of the most impressive
things about him and it's not you know
it's people look at it as bad but it's
he's him he's Kanye he is there for you
he you can look at him you can judge him
you can say whatever you wanted on but
he's
not a different person behind closed
doors right he is exactly the same
[ __ ] guy well maybe he's more
exciting maybe he's more on cents magic
though imagine because you see some of
what I do and you've seen a lot of it
for yourself but you you can see what
people are saying about you yes
now magnify that times 50 million
thousand like imagine the sense of self
that you need to have just in order to
get through a single [ __ ] day without
losing your mind
we are losing your mind without having a
million upon a million comments thrown
at you sway your idea of who you might
be you you would stay so strong to who
you are and you don't get you don't get
the you know distracted you don't get
any and nothing gets to you yeah I mean
yeah but okay just this sense of self
that you need to have is so great
now imagine that if you were told if you
played this game where you just fake it
you don't have to do with any of this
people aren't really going to talk [ __ ]
about you you're going to make you know
comfortable money you're gonna be nice
we'll keep you out of the tabloids
except for anything good or positive
like you're not going to be a
controversy all used to do is just shut
your mouth and be our puppet unity mean
like you're going to make everybody
money and this is that you know I mean
unless you're a perfect person so I feel
like Taylor Swift might be one of the
only examples so there's cheetos plenty
of stuff behind closed doors and nobody
[ __ ] knows about but she might be
just that person that's good enough
in actuality that she's may not be
really playing a game yeah I mean
there's there's plenty of other people
that come off as a perfect person and
then you know 5-10 years later down the
line they just lose your goddamn mind
and then you see who they really are as
a human being
join I mean so Kanye West has given
these options once you get big enough
like you can continue being you but
that's gonna be very controversial and
risky and incredibly risky for not only
you but your family everyone around you
everyone that works for you your record
label any any future things that you
want to do anything very risky or you
can play the safe game where you just
are our puppet and you act right you
blend in you say normal things you you
are
yourself but to a point dude I mean you
are all the good parts of yourself but
only that and then everything else you
need to hide imagine the sense of self
that you need to have to decide that the
route that requires me to be me and only
me regardless of the consequences or how
risky it might be I don't give a [ __ ]
about you I don't want to go this route
I want to do me imagine the sense of
self that you need to have in order to
do that it's it's the sense of self it
nobody has nobody well plenty of people
have it well I can think of one Kanye I
can think of like a few people REM well
yeah I mean there's a people who just
don't give a [ __ ] it's like when you
have people who are not playing by the
rules yes they have that mad sense of
self because they trust himself so much
that this whole system that's put in
place that you have to act this way and
do this one whatever is wrong is just
fine not worth it [ __ ] it I don't need
that and I think it's a combination of a
sense a sense of self and also just your
urge to kind of whether or not you want
to spread the message about being real
but you don't know anything else you
can't turn on a fake switch you whether
or not that's how you were raised or
whatever but you can't do it you can't
like you can't you think of my aunt
agree yourself to do heat just to give
you another example think about Gucci
mean you cannot be anyone but Gucci know
you you want to get an ice cream cone
tattooed on your face I can only be
Gucci mean I'm in court did you murder
this person or commit whatever crime
[ __ ] I might be are you busy which I
might be you cannot be anyone but good
you mean you're not capable of it your
your ass that's what I love about the
[ __ ] hip-hop community that not only
is it like the the culture of what that
whole genre of music embodies like [ __ ]
the system [ __ ] that [ __ ] this I'm I'm
self-made I value my voice and
everything but like there's no other
genre of anything that in like embodies
that rock-and-roll at the time that it
was at its height music you're talking
about no I mean like in
in the world of entertainment huh well I
was going to say to bring the
conversation full circle in a way Kanye
West is the Nick Diaz of the music
industry I mean you try to bring those
of you that don't know who Nick Diaz
Nick Diaz Lazar is uh he's from Stockton
California he's uh he just doesn't do
anything by anyone's rules but his he
goes to press conferences if he wants if
he doesn't want to go to a press
conference for a title fight three days
of war without a fight he won't go and
he's done that before he plays by his
own rules and it's been a nightmare for
his PR team for his manager for his
corner for his fight team furs you know
everything but he could be making so
much more money right now he could be
more popular if he played by the rules
you know what I mean but he's not
playing by the rules why is Nick Diaz
he's one of the best fighters alive
right and he's viewed as a special uh
you know he has a special place in
people's hearts he's like people love me
yes that plays bye no nervous yeah he
doesn't do what I mean I think that's a
great way to relate this to a different
thing and bring the conversation full
circle Nick Diaz is the Kanye West of
him you know of MMA and Kanye West is
very similar to how Nick Diaz acts like
you remember when Nick Diaz no showed
the press conference for GSP fight and
then he got poles in that fight the GSP
George st. Pierre the man everyone in
the world who's anything in MMA would
dream of fighting my teachers but didn't
show up to the press conference and he
got pulled from the fight he said [ __ ]
it he released a video like filming on
his phone in his car [ __ ] you I don't
want to go the press conference [ __ ] all
you haters right because nikki is my
just wants to fight he doesn't want to
do all the extra [ __ ] and Kanye West
just wants to [ __ ] do what he does
like you don't mean like that
he just wants to make really good music
and then just [ __ ] have be accepted
in the fashion industry you know what
Eddie Ria's purse absolutely and IDN do
the nothing oh yeah at the end of the
day Jenna when all the dust settles who
are you left [ __ ] thinking about are
you left thinking about the squares who
play by the rules or kind of blend in no
you like the people who stand on your
mind are the Kanye West's are the nick
Diaz's well okay sure I mean but that's
the thing like maybe that the cause of
them or holds them back from ever
achieving some sort of greatness that
they could have gotten if they had done
something
different yeah what nothing I was just
hoping for a response no I just I feel
like plenty of people stick out in your
mind and you everyone has a special
place in their heart for someone that
says [ __ ] the system yeah
not everyone has the balls to do that
you know what I mean because once you
get put in that situation you realize
like this probably isn't a great idea
like you start to feel the ramifications
of your choices and I feel like
certainly Nick Diaz and [ __ ] both of
the Diaz is really and and [ __ ] Kanye
have felt the ramifications for their
choices and sometimes the [ __ ] when you
lay your head down and I'm sure they
think did I make the right decision but
what always matters the most is that
you're like [ __ ] yeah I did you know
maybe next time if I was given an
opportunity I might give give it a
second thought I may do it differently
but for right now given my circumstances
[ __ ] yet they stand by their decision
[ __ ] yeah
yeah because I mean they wouldn't made
that decision if they didn't genuine
believe it was the right one
that's why does anyone never make any
decision why there are so few Nick Diaz
and Kanye West I think you know so many
people are just willing to do what
people tell them yeah because I feel
like you you have to see what you want
is more important than what anybody else
wants which becomes so clouded at ease
it's also perceived as egotistical
selfish that sort of thing do you
understand yeah it's perceived that way
but yeah I don't know I of course Kanye
I can understand the argument that
Kanye's a little bit he has an ego but
your [ __ ] rapper you have to have any
guy yeah yeah
you mean as much like okay someone that
doesn't really have an ego in some songs
Drake oh I like to rap about my
vulnerabilities next song is like I'm
the [ __ ] man [ __ ] everyone you know
what I mean like ensuring that because
he goes you do have to have an ego I
don't know I just think it's amazing and
[ __ ] I also I I'm not anticipating
that many people will agree with my
in of Kanye West because I know that
it's widely accepted to not understand
him and feel the way that you feel and
you're entitled to feel that way and it
is incredibly unpopular to I don't know
I just feel like a [ __ ] have watched
so many things where I'm like I get it I
get what you're saying and everyone
still seems to not understand you you
were in the vast minority but that
doesn't mean you're wrong but then when
I was I was at [ __ ] whatever office
and the I don't know what magazine it
was was an interview with him and he was
talking about Kim Kardashian and the
hole that the [ __ ] interviewers just
slamming him sort of been repeatedly
being like your girlfriend's like not
good at anything she's not really you
know famous she's just like it's weird
and Kanye just keeps defending her being
like she's the most famous woman in the
world what the [ __ ] is your problem like
what girl don't you understand she
really is and she's done it with her
entire [ __ ] family
yeah say what you will about her but
she's literally one of the most famous
who know she's creating a path that has
never been made before call it what you
want but yeah that's what it is it's
intense and it's [ __ ] I can't imagine
how scary it would be being Kim
Kardashian right now
but that's another opinion that people
don't like when you say that you have
sort of respect for someone like that or
a family like that because ever the easy
with easy thing to do was really rise
and be like oh my god I hate the card an
easy thing to do is put a cover over
everything she's done as she released a
sex tape like that yeah anyone uses of
sex tapes have gotten now money yeah Kim
Kardashian is where she is that no one
else's dude she I just feel like she's
sort of creating what what is possible
by being your own brand do you know what
I mean I think you can make that
argument I think that's very valid it's
just I think people don't see it that
way because of how she got the
opportunity to even make something of
herself or something hmm
you know hmm
yeah so huh whatever I [ __ ] love them
and I love Kanye you play that game iPad
you I haven't yet no it's really popular
it makes seven hundred thousand dollars
a day did you know that I've read
something like that yeah that's pretty
obscene it will because there's in-app
purchases but it's top of the App Store
it's been top the App Store for life
tell me that's not [ __ ] insane
brilliant like your wife is literally
the epitome of how is she including
something though well that's like people
say I'm not good at something or you
know anyone on YouTube isn't good at
something because someone didn't hire
you and say yes yeah we're plenty good
at plenty of things yeah yep yep just
when I said in the [ __ ] the Variety
magazine I said I had no tangible talent
as and I'm not a [ __ ] musician or an
actor right I'm you can't put me in a
box yeah
you cannot put Kim Kardashian in a box
therefore people have a problem with her
do you know what I mean though we don't
know how to categorize you therefore
your success is incredibly demeaning to
the rest of us yeah they don't
understand it so yeah I guess it's
easier to be like I [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] and she's disgusting and yes than
it is to sit down and try and understand
it and be like damn [ __ ] huh it's not
an easy thing to understand like I said
before you're pretty good at hearing
people and understanding them
thanks more than the i boring you do you
want to stop talking about the
Kardashians oh you know uh no I thought
that was a good conversation you want to
talk about Julian I don't know I don't
know um no I think it was interesting
talking about that because I think
you're in the vast minority and how you
think those Kanye and Kim Thanks
it's not a compliment Thanks you're
welcome
thank you is there anything else you
wanted to touch on for this podcast I
don't know just love drinking the
Crispin Crispian this is still my first
cider I'm really crushing it over here
yeah I finished too so there's that
and there's another one waiting for us
behind us well then yeah why don't we
[ __ ] in the end it
ah yeah well we hope you enjoyed this
podcast I know we did thank you for
watching
yeah if anyone ever wants to sit down
and have a very passionate conversation
with me about Kanye West I'll always be
here and I'll sit there and watch you
guys talk about it I'll be the third
party oh just have so many thoughts my
brain is full of thoughts okay that's a
good that's a good thing a good thing it
feels like it's not sometimes what it is
in the absence of thought we'll be back
next week with another podcast every
week but thank you so much for watching
every Monday right every Monday yep
subscribe to the channel we'll be
releasing new videos every Monday over
podcasts sometimes we have yet sometimes
we just sit here and drink a talk
actually always we sit here and drink
and talk at certain times there's a
third party but thank you for watching
follow us on all the stuff and we'll see
you guys next week bye love you bye